Oscar nominations were announced last  week one movie got a lot of Oscar  attention called Carole it's a movie  that stars Cate Blanchett sure 1 out of  300 always a good sign  apparently the lighting directors here  know Carole Oscar movie ask retention  for Carole starring Cate Blanchett and  Rooney Mara now the film is about a  young female photographer who develops  an intimate relationship with an older  woman now it's a great movie don't get  me wrong but I will say sometimes I  thought the director was too heavy  handed in implying a lesbian  relationship between the two main  characters I thought laid it on a little  thick see if you agree  it's not like  and yours Carol  Carroll  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  go check that movie out it wasn't that a  great clip subscribe to my youtube  channel for an endless supply of me  [Laughter]